hey what is up guys mkbhd here and no
good tech collection or setup is
complete without addressing audio now
it's pretty easy to just go with the
tame easy stuff in the audio department
but there is some pretty crazy stuff out
there and it could be just as fun to go
with that so this is dope tech speakers
all right so first things first yes this
is a hovering speaker this is called the
mars by crazy baby weird name yes and a
weird overall speaker as you can see it
floats there are some other actual
floating speakers on the market but i
picked this one because i think it's
number one the best looking and also
number two it's actually the most
functional this one's a two-part
bluetooth speaker so the bottom half is
a subwoofer and the top half is the
tweeter and the main claim to fame
besides the floating is that it produces
that 360 degree sound in a circle so it
sounds about the same no matter what
angle you're listening to it from mostly
because the subwoofer seems to fire
straight down and the tweeter fires your
sound straight up but there's no denying
the wow factor of a floating speaker the
base has magnets in it and it's pretty
easy to set up and use you just get the
disc in place and power it up and after
a few seconds the magnets inside the
base move up and push the disc into the
air in a pretty sweet balancing act the
whole thing is completely wireless too
so it runs on battery power for about
eight hours at a time and connects to
whatever device phone or tablet you want
plus it has its own app to wirelessly
control raising and lowering the disk
speaker from anywhere it has two usb
ports on the front as well so you can
charge your phone from the built-in
battery and it has a mic built in so i
guess this can be the ultimate meeting
room utility for that 360 degree
conference call if your boss is cool
enough to let you get one of these if
you want to know how they sound you
should check out my buddy john's video
on the tld channel where he has a whole
video all about these dedicated to how
they work and what they're like to own i
will link that one right below that like
button now audio is always a part of the
desk setup too you can't ignore that and
these red speakers here are called the
monroe sonic egg 100's yes they're
literally called eggs and they might
look familiar from my last video the top
5 upcoming tech or if you've seen it
from the dream desk 2. these are
obviously some pretty unique speakers
and i gotta say they're striking both
aesthetically in the way they look and
sonically they look cool and they sound
cool i'm pretty sure you won't find any
other pair of speakers that can accent a
setup as well as these now they have a
100 millimeter woofer on the bottom for
your lows and mids and a 25 millimeter
driver up top for your highs and the
overall like really well built quality
as a set of speakers but these aren't
just your normal set of studio monitors
most monitors you have at this level
including the ones on my current setup
have amplifiers inside of them meaning
they're internally amplified these eggs
are not the inside is literally just the
speaker drivers and electronics so
they're actually pretty lightweight and
then they come in the box with their own
dedicated amp that goes on the desk next
to them designed specifically to work
best with the speakers so custom cables
custom pre-amps custom everything
there's a high frequency adjustment and
low frequency adjustment for each
channel on the amp and this is where the
magic happens and they make it sound so
good and i'm not just saying that like
during the dream death setup we were
really cranking them and they sounded
very good they also have these sound
isolating rubber pads to keep them still
and that lets you actually point them
whatever direction you want you just
kind of prop it up on the rest and
they're called egg nests so that's
brilliant and overall as a package these
eggs are some of the most unique i've
seen as far as desktop audio solutions
go and they almost tempted me away from
my current yamahas i mean almost all
right last up is this little beast this
is called the wla phantom and it is an
absolute powerhouse of a speaker so the
phantom's main claim to fame is simple
as much power as you can possibly handle
coming in a tightly packaged package
it's about the size of a watermelon 3000
watts 105 decibels zero distortion i
mean it claims zero distortion i'm not
sure if i can vouch for that one but i
can definitely say this thing gets loud
it's also pretty unique to look at too
it's sitting in the middle of a room
kind of has this odd shape to it almost
like a teardrop silhouette or maybe like
an alien head and of course it'll turn
heads when you see it playing music
because the woofers on either side move
a lot the smallest driver is the one on
the end with the grille over it that's
the tweeter and then the mid-size driver
is actually the ring that surrounds it
that's a driver and then the woofers are
on either side firing outwards and these
two move a lot of air overall it's
definitely got this directional sound to
it so i'd almost opt to put it in the
corner of a room and just let it fill
the space with your beats but it still
works in the middle of a room you can
sort of bounce the sound off a wall now
the phantom is also a wireless speaker
but with a little more emphasis on
quality as it should for the price so it
does still have a power cable no battery
and then it has its own app called spark
for iphone or android or whatever you
use for the setup and organization but
you can still use it just like any other
bluetooth speaker if you want and yeah
this thing just gets ridiculously loud
and i'll be honest i haven't even heard
it at full volume yet because i live in
an apartment with other people and even
at two-thirds volume it's more than loud
enough to get a noise complaint which is
funny because i hear lots of noise from
my neighbors anyway there you have it
there's some dope tech in the audio
department but wait bonus item this is
something i've gotten questions about
like non-stop on twitter and youtube
comments sections for the past couple
months not my daily driver or anything
equipment related but
it's what was that light up lightning
cable in my iphone 6s review so this is
it and it's also going to be linked
below
it comes in a few different colors and
it even has a little sort of box at the
end controlling the firmware on the usb
end so the lights move a little bit
faster when your phone's almost empty
and actually slow down the lights when
your charge is almost done pretty dope
that's it for this episode thank you for
watching and i'll catch you guys in the
next one
peace